دمار في مايفيلد كنتاكي بعد أن
اجتاح إعصار تلك المدينة التي يبلغ عدد سكانها
حوالي 10000 شخص
، وكان براندون كليمنت مطاردًا للعواصف
التقط هذا الفيديو وهو ينضم
إلي الآن على الهاتف ، لذا فبراندون عندما
ننظر إلى هذه الصور أعني أنها
تبدو فقط  دخلت عربة بخارية عملاقة
لتوها من خلال
هدم كل شيء في طريقها
باستثناء
مبنيين مرنين هناك مباشرة ، يبدو هذا
وكأنه مبنى تاريخي من الطوب الذي
ننظر إليه هنا
وتلتقطه لقطات الطائرة بدون طيار ، لذا أخبرني
عن تجربتك
على طول الطريق ،
حيث كنت قادرًا أيضًا على التقاط هذه
الصور
جيدًا ، بدأت في أركنساس
وانتظرت وصول الإعصار
نحو ممر i-55 ، كنت أعرف أنه
سيكون سريع الحركة وكان يمر
عبر بعض المناطق الريفية الجميلة في
أركنساس
بمجرد عبور الطريق السريع i-55 السريع
55 على طول خط أركنساس ميسوري
، عبرت مسافة 300 ياردة
أمامي من خلال مجموعة من 18 عجلة وشبه
نصف.  وهناك طريقان مختلفان
هناك يقطعان
ويعبران النهر إلى تينيسي
ثم صعدت إلى أركنساس
وذهبت إلى ليتشفيل
ولسوء الحظ كان أحد الأشخاص قد تعرض
لوفاة وتحدث إلى العديد من الناس
عن الكثير من الدمار هناك  ثم شق
طريقي إلى منطقة كنتاكي ، لكن
عندما وصلت إلى مايفيلد ، كان الأمر مجرد
عدم مقارنة بما رأيته حتى
الآن في الماضي ، إنه تدمير كامل
وأعني أنني أرى
50 إلى 120 لتمرير عام  وهذا
هو أعلى اثنين أو ثلاثة في العقد الماضي